[Music]
let's go to david in
austin texas hey david what's going on
hey dr galoni good afternoon i hope
you're well
i'm good man how about you oh
well i was doing great i wouldn't be
calling you i think
i'm laughing with you not at you man um
right
cool so what's up brother how can i help
all right here's my issue
uh my wife and i just had our first baby
uh
actually a month ago yesterday and uh
i hey talk directly into the phone david
all right can you be better perfect so
you just you and your wife just had your
first baby a month ago how old are you
i'm 40. 40. all right you're in it now
brother
all right so you just had your first
baby and now what
uh well i'm finding out i don't really
like him
um it's not that i dislike him but he's
he's like a little
appliance that needs food and diaper
changing and this
paternal feeling that i'm supposed to
feel it hasn't arrived yet and i know
something's wrong and i don't know how
to
how to approach fixing it can i just
tell you something man
i yes you're a brave dude
and i have heard what you just said
so many times and it's a giant
secret that drowns new parents
and so i want to high-five you and
applaud you and tell you i'm grateful
for you reaching out
and for having the courage to say that
out loud have you told anybody else that
or am i the first person you're telling
us
no you you and your show okay well
dude i i'm grateful that you trusted me
that with
with that that's a heavy thing i know
you've been carrying around
so you have a new baby you're waiting
for all this run-up
nine months and then you have this baby
did the birth go well everything went
fine normal
everything went really textbook at the
very end we wound up doing a
cesarean um which wasn't planned but
every
everything's healthy okay everything's
how it should be okay
and then you get home and it's a month
later
and you were waiting for this big
like angels to start singing and the
music to swell
and all you have is this little wrinkled
up lump of a human that stole your wife
from you and now it's taking all your
money and just
craps all day and doesn't sleep and
pretty much ruining everything
is that about right yeah
yeah i've got two of them man and
so what were you expecting to feel man
well kind of what i'd heard my entire
life is the first time you hold
your baby it doesn't matter how it comes
out how healthy it is
how whatever you're just going to melt
you're going to feel emotions you've
never felt before
you're going to step lighter walk
stronger and be a better man from then
on
and it's it's like i'm babysitting
yeah hey whoever told you that wasn't
telling you the truth
okay maybe some dudes have that i didn't
have that the first time i held my son
i think my words were oh crap this is
for real
right yeah and i'll tell you right now
my son's 11 years old
and i love him deeper than i knew i had
capacity for i didn't
i found chambers of my heart that i
didn't know existed
but it wasn't on day one
it wasn't on day five it wasn't on day
30. we had to grow into it
it was a chore i had things i had to do
here's what was really hard
i was an older parent like you are okay
i wasn't 40 but i was in my 30s
so i had a structure i had things that i
knew i liked i had things
i know the way i work and how i can be
successful and suddenly all that got
dumped over
right and so i'm not you're having to
learn everything on the fly
and you're 40 bro give yourself some
grace
okay what i want you to do is to
not let this lack of emotion this lack
of feeling
turn into a lack of doing the right
things
yeah i can understand that i think i do
yeah you know i care for him
i change him i hold him okay yeah
and i want you to talk to him i want you
to continue to show up
and love love love his mama
serve her take care of her as she heals
from a major surgery we just kind of
blow through yeah i had a c-section
that's a major surgery man
yeah it is honor her love her you're
gonna have a season with no sleep or
very little sleep you're gonna have a
season where your work schedule's all
screwed up and your marriage is all
weird
and you don't know what you just look
and all of that gets zeroed in on this
little
bitty guy over here in the corner
and man it's hard
i'm sure there are guys who held their
baby and the chorus
like it all came it didn't happen for me
my daughter was different and it's not
just because she was my daughter but she
was i knew what to expect at this point
so i knew that um these little
miracles are pretty resilient you're not
gonna break them
and my son by that time had taught me so
much about myself it was a gift
and so there is a
i don't call it a depression because
that sounds um
that sounds prescriptive and i don't do
that
there's going to be a dip you're going
to have a low
where you just get exhausted you're
going to have to know when you've got to
reach out for help you're going to have
to have a buddy or two that you can text
and reach out to and
say hey is this normal and they'll go
yeah sucks huh
or yeah dude just change the diaper get
over yourself and you need to have those
guys in your life and if you don't have
them get them today
okay that may even be your old man and
uh
but you gotta have some guys in your
life that you've got at the text at
on your text on a text thread that you
can just communicate at a moment's
notice
and then you got to know when hey honey
i need to go for a walk right now
you got to know when i'm not doing okay
i need to call a counselor because i'm
i'm thinking of bolting on this deal i'm
thinking of walking out the door because
i'm
going to tell you this dave you're not
going to walk out the door is that right
that's correct you're in is that right
yes good so now now it's a matter of
choosing to do the right things
i think in my heart you love this kid
it feels different than you thought it
was gonna feel or that they told you it
was gonna feel whoever they is
right and here's what's awesome if you
have another one in four years
i know you're going no way man yep i'm
putting it on you dude
you have another one in four years
you're gonna tell everybody
when i held my first son my light
everything just changed man you're just
in the fog of the first 30 days okay
so i want to tell you i don't think
you're crazy do you think you're crazy
i don't think i'm crazy okay you just
think you got lied to
well i mean now after speaking with you
i think that's probably the case
uh before when i was waiting on hold i i
was thinking you know what's wrong with
me
listen if every guy was like all right
listen here's what's happening
you're gonna lose your wife for about
two years and
um this kid's gonna take 90 of your
income
and is going to crap everywhere oh
and they tell you you got to change a
diaper no it's 10 a day
a day forever and then your buddies are
finally gonna be like hey you
we've been we've been waiting for a
couple of years we're ready to start the
business you all in and you're like
nope gotta hang out with the kid because
wife's gonna go what
if if everyone told everyone that no one
would have kids right
and here's the other thing in short
order you're gonna have a buddy reach
out to you
because this happened to me this
happened my buddy john king one of my
best friends on planet earth
he has a baby and
maybe six months eight months in we all
got together every week
every monday night we got together as a
group of us
then slowly he quit coming dude what is
he doing
and his wife jen is incredible she's one
of my best
she's one of the best best friends in
the world hilarious awesome
but dude i was like man this guy's wife
is killing him
he can't even go out with us one night a
week what is the deal here
and he was always so honoring of his
wife of his new baby
and it was about six months after i had
hank that that group of guys called me
and like hey guys we're gonna go out and
i started saying
no man i'd never occurred to me that
he'd rather sit at home and hold this
little lump of a six month old and go
hang out with our idiots
right more on faces at some bar
somewhere
all that to tell you is this
don't beat yourself up over how you're
feeling do the right thing
make sure you're loving that kid you're
touching that kid you are hugging that
kid you're holding that kid you're
taking him outside you're taking them
all walks changing his diapers
you're doing all those things that you
need to do make sure you have a
community of guys around you
right that you are eating right that
you're moving you're exercising that
you're sleeping when you can
keep doing the things that you know
you've got to do to keep you healthy
and i promise you
you will feel new parts of your heart
begin to open up and it's slow
and it's a pro it's a it's a it's a
journey and then you'll go whoa
it'll be the first time you go for a
walk and a dog comes
running at you in the stroller and you
find yourself saying
that dog's gonna die right then you
think well where'd that come from i like
dogs
and i like dogs too but not more than my
kid right you'll find these moments
somebody will mouth off to you your kid
in a restaurant
and then your eyes will turn black and
you'll realize
or you'll hear that cry and you'll pop
up in the middle of the night and you'll
want to go
grab them out of the bassinet whatever
it is it looks different for everybody
don't beat yourself up you're a good dad
you're not going anywhere dave you're
gonna stick around you're a good dad
you're all in feelings or feelings and
emotions or emotions don't beat yourself
up man
keep keep doing the right things keep
doing the right things thank you so much
for that call david man you made my
heart feel good and you made me
ah you reminded me
man
we oh man i don't want to get on some
james i don't get on some tan right
some rant here
there is no right way to feel about some
of these things
oh when i got married i was gonna feel
this i thought as soon as he
asked me to marry him i'd feel like that
and i thought when i found out i would
be pregnant this i'd feel like this and
um i thought as soon as i held my baby
like david man i thought this would all
be
me and there is no external
plug to an internal hole there is
nothing out there quote unquote that
will fix you
in here
and we have all these instagrammed and
and pinterestized and
great grandma-eyes directions on how
we're supposed to feel on some of these
major life milestones and if you don't
feel that way
or you don't think that you feel that
way you think you're broken
you think there's something wrong with
you or something wrong with your
relationship or something wrong with
your kid
often you're not you just feel different
and that's when you've got to write down
these feelings do you really not love
your kid no of course you do
do you really not love this guy who just
asked you to marry him of course you do
i don't know maybe you don't maybe you
don't but
generally speaking yes so what's true
about this it feels different
i gotta go plan a wedding and that's
gonna be hard yep doesn't mean you don't
love it means it doesn't feel the same
way you thought it was going to
that's okay that's okay
feel these feelings write them down and
then demand evidence from them
and like brave david did call somebody
call somebody if you don't know have
some people in your life you can reach
out to and be honest with me
david i'm proud of you brother you're
awesome you're awesome
um i'm gonna leave it at that man i'm
gonna leave it at that